Greetings!
Class of 2024, transfer students
Eli Whitney students,
and visiting
international students,
welcome to Yale!
I'm Marvin Chun, Dean of
Yale College
and on behalf of the officers
of the university, the faculty,
the heads and deans of the
residental colleges,
and the deans and staff members
of the Yale College
Dean's Office,
I am so pleased to
be with you today.
Family members and friends who
are joining us, we extend our
warm welcome to you
and we thank you for everything
you have done to guide
these young adults.
In my role as dean, one of my
jobs is to support President
Salovey's mission
for Yale to be the research
university most committed to
teaching and learning.
What that means for you students
is that I am here to make sure
that you get the best
of what Yale has to offer, in
the classroom or outside of it.
A good part of what you will
learn here will come from the
faculty who will teach you
in the classes you take,
while much will come from
your peers and colleagues.
Taken together, these teachers
of yours will give you the
liberal education that
is Yale's hallmark.
By the time you graduate, you
will have furnished your mind
in the broadest possible sense,
not by pursuing narrow,
specialized fields of study
but instead by searching for
new knowledge, new perspectives,
new ways of looking at the
world, and by adding your own.
If you make good of this place,
you will discover fields of
knowledge that are
completely new to you, that you
haven't even heard of,
and you will open yourselves
to them and learn from them.
You're joining Yale during a
uniquely challenging year
for the institution
and for the world.
The ongoing pandemic
requires us to curtail
in-person group gatherings,
and so most of your classes and
activities will be conducted
online, starting with this
Opening Assembly.
Still, we can be grateful that
in year 2020, modern
technology equips us
to overcome this challenge
better than ever.
Online, we can stay connected,
communicating our ideas,
and sharing our passions.
As a neuroscientist, I can
assure you that to your brain
nestled inside of your head,
sights and sounds from the
world can be as vivid online
as they would be live.
You don't need to be a
neuroscientist to understand
that whether listening with
headphones or from a person
standing in front of you,
the sound waves reaching your
ears are similar; and that
whether the face you're seeing
is on a screen or across
the classroom, the images
you are seeing are comparable.
If not for our agility with
media, which brings us
the world every day,
how could the music, film, and
broadcasting industries be such
a dominant form of entertainment
in our daily lives?
As you imagine the semester
ahead, think about new ways
you will interact with the
faculty and other students,
just as your
instructors will be.
Also keep in mind that the
faculty-to-student ratio is the
best in Yale's modern history,
with more faculty teaching and
mentoring fewer students.
You are entering Yale when its
diverse faculty is the largest
it has ever been,
and at a time when the number of
enrolled students is around
80% its usual size.
One of the unanticipated
advantages of starting your
Yale education now
is the increased attention
you will receive.
Still, with much of the
semester now online,
with fewer people around,
you may be more
easily distracted,
and if you're like me you might
be guilty of occasional
mind wandering.
In fact, my own desire to be
more focused has led to a
research interest in attention
throughout my career.
My lab group uses brain scanners
to measure how attentive a
person is,
and we explore ways to
improve concentration.
So here, let me make good use of
this online moment
to help you be more attentive
to the new ideas
and opportunities that
await you at Yale.
I will now direct you to an
on-screen demonstration
of how you can focus better
to make distractions disappear.
You see a background of
flickering blue dots
with three stationary and
salient yellow dots
forming a triangle.
In the middle is a
white plus sign,
and I'll ask you to just
stare at that throughout
this exercise.
If you stay focused on the
white plus symbol without
moving your eyes,
you should notice that
the yellow dots will
start disappearing.
It may take a few seconds for
this to happen for you,
especially if you're
distracted right now.
The yellow dots will start
disappearing one or two
at a time,
but for many of you all three
of them should disappear
at some point.
This is a perceptual illusion
called motion-induced blindness
and at Yale, Psychology
Professor Brian Scholl
studies it.
There are many explanations
for why motion-induced
blindness occurs,
but for today's purpose,
just know that you can willfully
make distractions disappear.
With your new found powers of
attention, you not only
can reduce distraction,
you can use it to help you see
new perspectives and new
ways of understanding.
Your have all earned a place
in this community because of the
promise that you have shown
in what you will contribute
to it, and you have so much
to learn from each other.
When you get to know
your colleagues joining
Yale this year,
you will discover that you come
from every possible walk of life
bringing with you every
imaginable talent,
every experience,
every worldview.
Think about how to leverage
your different backgrounds,
views, talents, and interests,
and by learning how to see the
world through each other's eyes.
It takes effort and attention
to put yourself in
someone else's shoes,
and it will be worth it to
empathize with others
and to make
more informed decisions.
Okay, so now let's turn to
another demonstration
to use your mind and volition
to see things differently.
You should see two dots
moving on the screen now.
Do you see them moving
vertically, up and down in
columns?
Or do you see them moving
horizontally, oscillating
between left and right in rows?
Some of you will
see them moving vertically,
and others will
see them moving horizontally.
This simple demonstration shows
a fundamental principle
of psychology:
we all experience the
world differently.
Our perceptual interpretations,
our memories, and our thoughts,
are all constructs of the mind,
and they differ across people
even when they consider the same
object, event, or evidence.
Now I will ask you to see the
dot motions differently using
your mindset and attention.
If you see them moving
vertically, try to see them move
along the horizontal axis,
and if you see them moving
horizontally, try to see them
move along the vertical axis.
It's hard, but you can do it,
and if you can't, be assured
that we still want you at Yale.
But since we don't really have
time now here's a hint.
Use your hand to
cover up the bottom row,
and this will help you
see the dots move horizontally.
Or use your hand to
cover up the right column,
and you will
see the dots move vertically.
Take your hand away
and the motion should stick.
Here's a final example of
how you can view one image
two different ways.
Name out loud what you see.
Did you see a duck?
Or did you see a rabbit?
Can you see it both ways?
Your hand won't help here,
but the duck's bill
forms the rabbit's ears,
and the rabbit's nose
is the back of the duck's head.
Now look at the
cartoon on the screen.
Two armies face each other,
and for the army on the bottom,
find the general at the front
of it, urging his troops
with his sword:
How can we help everyone
understand that they are
serving the same flag?
Yale will expose you to views
different from your own,
and when it does, you can
start by finding common ground
with people when you
don't agree with them.
As Yalies, as our newest
members of Bulldog Nation,
you are all under one flag.
With the sophomores,
juniors, and seniors,
the alumni,
faculty, and staff,
and with each other.
You have common ground,
an immediate shared bond
that goes deep,
to the intellectual curiosity
and the commitment to community
that have brought
you all here.
You have just arrived at a
place that values difference
and actively seeks it out.
It is how
professors and students
find and test knowledge,
and it is how the university
equips its students, that's you,
to become leaders and
citizens of the world.
But here, the value of
seeking difference is
even more than that.
Here it is taken as an
article of faith, it is the
coin of the realm,
it is one of the bedrock
principles that governs us
in and out of the classroom.
Let me assume that you have
come here not only
to find knowledge,
but also to learn how to
live lives of consequence.
If that is true, you have
come to the right place.
As you take your first steps
then, you will need to become
comfortable with difference,
not just to accept it,
or tolerate it,
but to insist on it.
You will find guides everywhere,
in the classes you take,
the activities you join,
and most of all from the
people joining you right now,
your peers and classmates.
All of them are part of the
liberal arts education
that awaits you.
Your life at Yale has started,
and as it does, here's what
I hope you will do.
If you are a duck person,
go find those rabbit people and
find common ground with them.
If you are studying lots of
duck courses, go find
the rabbit courses
and see what they can teach you.
And when you find yourself
rallying around a duck flag
take a good hard look at that
rabbit flag across the field and
the people rallying around it,
and remember that
you are all Yalies.
Members of the Class of 2024,
transfer students,
Eli Whitney students,
Visiting International Students,
you belong to Yale, and
Yale belongs to you. Welcome!